how are you coping I'm a little jealous
of your quarantine partner Martine you
must be getting like a lot of attention
right now he truly is it's so funny the
timing of all of this but yeah I that's
all she knows so hopefully when I get
back on the road um she's okay with it
there's no separation anxiety although
she's gonna be coming everywhere with me
so she's been and she's been a dream
definitely keeping keeping me busy yeah
she's not gonna be like a 200 pounds
you know gigantic dog so you can bring
her pretty much wherever yeah have you
been keeping up in this a lot of my
friends have been spending a lot of time
on like animal crossing or baking cakes
or like in your idling time what do you
find yourself doing I know it's like are
you even in quarantine if you haven't
made banana bread like right I actually
myself have not but that still on the
to-do list
I've been keeping pretty busy with work
I put together a little home studio and
I've been really enjoying just having
this time to you know dive in to bold
music and listen to albums from start to
finish in one sitting with no
distractions and I don't know I it's
it's had its ups and downs for sure
there are days when I wake up and I'm
like I truly don't know what to do with
myself I am not used to being home as
much but I have found that it's been
really nice and I've been with my family
as well so that's been great do you find
that it's sort of forcing you to tap
into a different way to be creative and
when you performed on Fallon with the
set that your mom kind of moved all the
furniture around for those are all sort
of it's all very DIY and in a way for me
it looks like it's kind of liberating it
is it is actually I mean it's obviously
I think it's forced anyone and everyone
regardless of what you're doing to be
creative you know um with birthday
drive-bys and you know friends are
having baby showers and all these things
are happening and it's amazing how
they're going on with their lives and
they're doing what they can to still
make these moments special and make them
count
um but yeah as far as you know
creativity it's definitely
definitely different but it's fun I mean
it's it's kept me on my toes it's been a
challenge figuring out how to pull off a
performance from home but I'm not No
thank God for my mom because she really
helpful though yeah family first right
family makes it work now half written
story you know it seems like it comes
from a very particular place you had a
very clear sort of direction and
emotional life in the in this EP where
was your head and heart at when you put
this together
very sad dark place I I had just well
well I started writing this right after
I finished season one of my show
Dickinson and I got that you know
experience was I mean a blessing because
it worked has served as such a
distraction for me I was going through a
lot in my personal life and and I
thankfully luckily had somewhere else
and a lot of other people to show up for
daily so it kept me sort of you know
preoccupied but when it came time to
wrap that up and come home and get in
the studio you know during the process
of that filming I you know I think a lot
of us don't necessarily want to feel
pain so we do things to avoid it or
distract ourselves and there was part of
me that was like wanting to push away
all of the pain and forget about
everything that I was thinking about
every second of every day but there was
a small part of me that was like don't
lose this cuz I gotta focus on this show
but when I get home I've got I really
want to make records that sound the way
I feel right now and so I really feel
like I was able to accomplish that with
these few records that are on the
project and um yeah I'm really proud of
them yeah you know one of those big jobs
as an artist is to sit kind of in the
emotion and like that's the courage of
an artist to dive headfirst into the
pain did it give you a different outlook
or a different idea of what love is and
what it potentially could be just going
through writing in yeah yeah I mean I'm
I think you know who love is a funny
thing and there are different versions
of it I think different people have
different ideas about love different
approaches to love and I think that's
all a part of life and learning and
growing is you you figure out what those
are but as far as writing and I just
think that writing for me has always
been a form of release whether it's in
song form or just in a diary that nobody
will ever see it's always since I was I
mean I mean as far back as I can
remember I've always written down what
I've felt and so it's it's definitely I
recommend it to anybody going through
something because I do think it's such a
great form of release yeah now this is
half written story so what is the other
half of the story sound like and feel
like well because you know how to wait
and see you know obviously with
everything that's going on in the world
things have changed for for everyone
everywhere and especially as far as you
know scheduling and with this project I
really just wanted to get these records
out that I love and I'm so proud of and
I'm feeling my fans have been so
incredibly patient
I don't know how they've hung on for
this long but I wanted to you know give
them the little treat that is half
written story in the meantime as I
continue working on the bigger body work